Lucia: 但加一个那个蛋
Lucia: But add an egg.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Lucia: 所以他是锅贴吗
Lucia: So is this a potsticker?
Shure:  差不多吧
Shure: Pretty much.
陌生人：我没吃过
Stranger: I've never had it.
陌生人：我一直以为正宗的叫火鸡
Stranger: I always thought the authentic name was turkey.
Alice: 哦下面还有层嗯
Alice: Oh, there's another layer underneath.
陌生人：我靠下面还有一层
Stranger: Wow, there's another layer underneath.
Lucia: 哦这种东西叫锅贴
Lucia: Oh, this thing is called a potsticker.
Lucia: 那这个是什么
Lucia: So what is this?
Lucia: 尝一下
Lucia: Try it.
陌生人：像什么什么香河肉饼那种
Stranger: It's like those Xianghe meat pies.
Alice: 为什么没有人吃腊八蒜
Alice: Why is no one eating Laba garlic?
Shure:  我吃糖蒜
Shure: I eat sweet garlic.
Shure:  但不吃腊八蒜
Shure: But not Laba garlic.
Alice: 为啥
Alice: Why?
Shure:  因为就是他是坏掉的
Shure: Because it's basically spoiled.
Katrina:  少忽悠我
Katrina: Stop fooling me.
Shure:  不是腊八蒜
Shure: It's not Laba garlic.
Alice: 腊八蒜
Alice: Laba garlic.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Alice: 糖蒜有皮
Alice: Sweet garlic has skin.
Jake: 那是什么蒜
Jake: What kind of garlic is that?
Jake: 腊八蒜
Jake: Laba garlic.
Lucia: 腊八蒜
Lucia: Laba garlic.
Shure:  腊八蒜他这个是就是熟的蒜
Shure: Laba garlic is basically cooked garlic.
Shure:  那个糖弄糖蒜的时候是那种新鲜的蒜
Shure: When you make sweet garlic, you use fresh garlic.
Shure:  就是那种
Shure: The kind that...
Shure:  没没没烘过的那种蒜
Shure: The kind that hasn't been dried.
Jake: 这是什么
Jake: What is this?
Lucia: 不知道
Lucia: No idea.
Lucia: 看起来像一个饼
Lucia: Looks like a pancake.
Jake: 早餐10块
Jake: Breakfast, 10 bucks.
Jake: 饼
Jake: Pancake.
Jake: 撕了吧
Jake: Tear it up.
Jake: 就在这撕了吧
Jake: Just tear it up here.
Lucia: 累死了
Lucia: I'm exhausted.
Jake: 就在这撕掉
Jake: Tear it up right here.
Jake: 看看怎么撕
Jake: Let's see how you tear it.
Shure:  撕什么
Shure: Tear what?
Jake: 撕饼
Jake: Tear the pancake
Lucia: 这也是香椿的吗
Lucia: Is this also Chinese toon?
Alice: 这个是茴香的啊
Alice: This one is fennel
Jake: 撕完了哎
Jake: Done tearing it
Jake: 没撕完还有一个
Jake: Not done yet, there's one more
Jake: 自行认领
Jake: Claim it yourself
Katrina:  我觉得吃两个就吃饱了
Katrina: I think eating two will fill me up
Jake: 你说8个
Jake: You said eight
Katrina:  我今天早上吃多了面包
Katrina: I ate a lot of bread this morning
Katrina:  今天早上那个
Katrina: This morning
Katrina:  自己做面包
Katrina: I made the bread myself
Katrina:  烤面包大厨的感觉
Katrina: Felt like a master baker
Tasha: 不知道什么东西
Tasha: Don't know what it is
Katrina:  黄油面包
Katrina: Butter bread
Shure:  昨天没吃到
Shure: Didn't get to eat it yesterday
Shure:  我的我的
Shure: My bad, my bad
Shure:  我的肉
Shure: My meat
Shure:  虽然不是我烤的吧
Shure: Even though I didn't grill it
Shure:  你应该感到很悲伤吧
Shure: You must feel sad, right?
陌生人：很悲伤什么
Stranger: Sad about what?
Lucia: 你吃吧
Lucia: Go ahead and eat
Lucia: 昨晚太晚了
Lucia: It was too late last night
Lucia: 太晚吃 9点了
Lucia: Eating too late, it was 9 o'clock
Jake: 我们几点考完来着
Jake: What time did we finish grilling?
Jake: 9点半10点半
Jake: 9:30 or 10:30
Alice: 10点半
Alice: 10:30
Shure:  都12点了
Shure: It was almost midnight
Alice:快12点了
Alice: Almost 12
Alice: 对就是
Alice: Yeah, that's right
Jake: 肯定烤上
Jake: Definitely started grilling
Jake: 什么时候烤上呢
Jake: When did we start grilling?
Jake: 还不知道
Jake: Still don't know
Katrina:  搞碳就搞了半天碳
Katrina: Spent half the day on the charcoal
Katrina:  我看看拍照时间
Katrina: Let me check the photo time
Alice: 每根头发丝都裹裹满了
Alice: Every strand of hair covered
Alice: 那个烟的味道
Alice: With the smell of smoke
Katrina:  真的是所以必须要洗到洗
Katrina: Really, had to wash it out
Shure:  昨天晚上我还倒头就睡了
Shure: I fell asleep right away last night
Shure:  我靠昨天晚上
Shure: Damn, last night
Katrina: 9点半吃上第一个串
Katrina: Started eating the first skewer at 9:30
Shure:  躺那躺一会
Shure: Just lie down for a bit.
Shure:  然后就着了
Shure: Then you'll fall asleep.
Jake: 谁赢了
Jake: Who won?
陌生人：还好我没看
Stranger: Good thing I didn't watch.
Jake: 是吧你
Jake: Right?
Jake: 你是曼城球迷
Jake: You're a Man City fan.
Jake: 哈兰德
Jake: Haaland.
Jake: 哈哈哈啊
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure:  曼彻斯特
Shure: Manchester.
陌生人：其实我是姆巴佩的球
Stranger: Actually, I'm an Mbappé fan.
陌生人：所以我很期待姆巴佩打皇马
Stranger: So I'm really looking forward to Mbappé playing against Real Madrid.
陌生人：马上要去皇马了
Stranger: He's about to join Real Madrid.
陌生人：看看他们操作
Stranger: Let's see how they do.
Lucia: 嗯他真的要去皇马了吗
Lucia: Is he really going to Real Madrid?
Jake: 打巴黎赢了吗
Jake: Did they beat Paris?
Jake: 就是要打皇马
Jake: I mean, Real Madrid.
陌生人：赢了
Stranger: Yeah, they won.
陌生人：马上还要打多特
Stranger: Next, they have to play Dortmund.
陌生人：然后皇马打多特蒙德
Stranger: Then Real Madrid will play Dortmund.
Jake: 我以前都不知道
Jake: I never knew before.
Jake: 达瓦尼自从我做这个和这个
Jake: Since I started doing this and that.
Jake: 啊就这个是我们
Jake: Ah, so this is our...
Jake: 我2022年的一篇paper
Jake: My 2022 paper.
Jake: 他态度比较
Jake: His attitude is kind of...
Jake: 这个叫叫panelbig
Jake: This thing is called "panelbig."
陌生人：确实你知道
Stranger: You know, actually...
陌生人：当时一开就是大巴黎
Stranger: Back then, Paris Saint-Germain just started.
Jake: 对就是这个
Jake: Yeah, exactly.
Jake: 是80年代TSG
Jake: It's from the 80s, TSG.
Jake: 就是大巴黎的那个logo
Jake: It's the Paris Saint-Germain logo.
Jake: 嗯然后我们稍微改造改造
Jake: Then we made some modifications.
Jake: 改成了我们这个分割的
Jake: Changed it to our segmented version.
Jake: 就它是一个情景分割
Jake: It's a contextual segmentation.
Jake: 嗯一看是青年分支
Jake: And at first glance, it looks like a youth branch.
Jake: 就就就割出来的这个东西
Jake: It's like, you know, this thing.
Shure:  所以这个跟大巴黎是真的有关系是吗
Shure: So this really has something to do with Paris Saint-Germain?
Jake: 简称是就是PSG啊
Jake: The abbreviation is PSG.
Jake: 就硬凑一个简称
Jake: We just forced an abbreviation.
Shure:  就是正好这个简称是一样的是吗
Shure: So the abbreviation just happens to be the same?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 就是先出了这个名字
Jake: So we came up with this name first
Jake: 然后简称PSG
Jake: Then we abbreviated it to PSG
Jake: 然后我上网一搜
Jake: And when I searched online
Jake: 我靠是个球队
Jake: Wow, it's a football team
Jake: 哈哈我才知道
Jake: Haha, that's when I found out
Lucia: 巴黎圣日耳曼
Lucia: Paris Saint-Germain
Shure:  大巴黎他不止有球队
Shure: PSG is not just a football team
Shure:  还有那个电竞的队伍嗯
Shure: They also have an esports team, yeah
Shure:  吃困了
Shure: I'm so sleepy
Shure:  吃完就想睡
Shure: After eating, I just want to sleep
Shure:  睡醒了就饿
Shure: After sleeping, I wake up hungry
Shure:  饿完就想吃
Shure: And then I want to eat again
Shure:  感觉人生已经
Shure: I feel like my life is just
Jake: 对这才是生活
Jake: Yeah, this is life
Jake: 一个life就应该这个样子
Jake: This is how life should be
Jake: 跟里面夹了很多戏
Jake: Full of drama
Jake: 太那个了
Jake: It's just too much
Shure:  不真实我们
Shure: It's unreal for us
Shure:  明天床上躺一天啊
Shure: Let's just lie in bed all day tomorrow
Shure:  对
Shure: Yeah
Shure:  像只蛆一样的蠕动
Shure: Wiggle around like a maggot
陌生人：我在床上躺一天
Stranger: I lie in bed all day
陌生人： 你应该给我个300
Stranger: You should give me 300 for that
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Shure:  我靠我让你看我在床上躺着
Shure: Damn, I'll let you watch me lying in bed
Lucia: 你都是看天花板
Lucia: You're just staring at the ceiling
陌生人：我又看不到你躺着可以吧
Stranger: I can't even see you lying down, is that okay?
Shure:  那我把眼镜放这块
Shure: Then I'll put my glasses here
Shure:  然后让他拍
Shure: And let him take a picture
Shure:  我躺着就是让他
Shure: Of me lying down, just for him
Jake: 那为什么会眼镜
Jake: Why glasses though?
Shure:  人类是一个草履虫
Shure: Humans are like paramecium
Shure:  只能进行简单的生命活动
Shure: Only capable of simple life activities
Lucia: 哈哈哈救命啊
Lucia: Hahaha, save me
Shure:  感觉吃的差不多了
Shure: I feel like I've eaten enough
Shure:  我好饿啵啵
Shure: I'm so hungry, boo
Shure:  呸我好好饱
Shure: Pfft, I'm so full
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Jake: 谢斌竹什么时候答辩
Jake: When is Xie Binzhu defending his thesis?
Jake: 模拟答辩
Jake: Mock defense
陌生人：导师太懒了不搞
Stranger: The advisor is too lazy to do it
Katrina:  这跟导师有关
Katrina: This is related to the advisor
Katrina:  我以为是学员
Katrina: I thought it was the students
陌生人：嗯他想怎么打怎么打
Stranger: Yeah, he can grade however he wants
Jake: 就学院要求
Jake: It's a requirement of the college
Jake: 但是导师不管
Jake: But the advisor doesn't care
陌生人：但是按装
Stranger: But according to...
陌生人：有的老师应该会给我打最高分
Stranger: Some teachers would give me the highest score
Jake: 为什么
Jake: Why
陌生人：因为他前几次从来没看过对手推广
Stranger: Because he never reviewed the opponent's promotion in the previous rounds
Lucia: 哇这样的导师哪里找
Lucia: Wow, where can you find such an advisor
陌生人：然后之前
Stranger: And earlier
陌生人：我还问了一下
Stranger: I even asked
陌生人： 就我的导师是我老板他
Stranger: My advisor is my boss, and he
陌生人：然后他没名额了
Stranger: And he had no more spots
陌生人：挂了一个导师
Stranger: So he assigned me another advisor
陌生人：然后他问了个老板
Stranger: Then he asked a boss
陌生人： 我说我要不要去加他微信啊
Stranger: I asked if I should add him on WeChat
陌生人：要不要搞
Stranger: Should I do it
陌生人：他说能不烦他尽量别烦他
Stranger: He said if you can avoid bothering him, don't bother him
Jake: 反他就扣分
Jake: If you bother him, he will deduct points
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure:  你只要跟我说一句话我就给你扣一分
Shure: If you say one word to me, I'll deduct one point
陌生人：所以我都好多天没跟他讲过一句话
Stranger: So I haven't spoken to him for many days
Jake: 准备满分准备满分
Jake: Get ready for full marks, get ready for full marks
Jake: 准备满分
Jake: Get ready for full marks
陌生人：班只说过一次
Stranger: I only spoke to him once in class
陌生人：最开始给他发了邮件
Stranger: Initially, I sent him an email
陌生人：他回我一切信息
Stranger: He replied with all the information
陌生人：请不要联系我
Stranger: Please do not contact me
陌生人： 联系男老师就行
Stranger: Contact the male teacher instead
Shure:  男老师是什么东西
Shure: What's a male teacher
陌生人：就是当然的了啊
Stranger: It's just the usual thing
陌生人：最新的地点是20号叫中的名称
Stranger: The latest location is called Zhong on the 20th
陌生人：嗯然后就24号叫皮皮虾
Stranger: And then on the 24th, it's called Pipi Shrimp
Shure:  嗯 24号叫final report
Shure: Yeah, the 24th is called the final report
Shure:  30号
Shure: The 30th
陌生人：皮皮30号中间没了
Stranger: Pipi Shrimp on the 30th, then nothing in between
陌生人：21号章没了
Stranger: Seal number 21 is gone.
Shure:  没有24号
Shure: There's no number 24.
Shure:  就是所有周边材料
Shure: All the surrounding materials...
Shure:  加上那个那什么都要交
Shure: Plus that thing, everything needs to be submitted.
陌生人：这挺好这是RGG
Stranger: This is pretty good, this is RGG.
陌生人：  原来那个是鲁差的地位啊
Stranger: So that was Lu's status.
Shure:  那是他什么的弟弟啊
Shure: That's his brother.
陌生人：他们班他们才抓住
Stranger: Their class finally caught them.
Shure:  唉
Shure: Sigh...
Shure:  你drop的写多少了
Shure: How much did you write for the drop?
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
陌生人：再编点数据
Stranger: Fabricate some more data.
陌生人：交了个翻译的程序
Stranger: Submitted a translation program.
Jake: 我当年毕设什么初期报告忘交了
Jake: I forgot to submit my initial report for my graduation project back then.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake: 对对恶劣伪报扣了10%
Jake: Yeah, for malicious falsification, they deducted 10%.
Jake: 最后90
Jake: Ended up with 90.
Shure:  对最后90
Shure: Yeah, ended up with 90.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 哈最后90
Lucia: Haha, ended up with 90.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Shure:  是因为人家做的很牛逼
Shure: It's because what you did was really impressive.
Jake: 没有没有
Jake: No, no.
Shure:  你这你就是你
Shure: You are... you...
Shure:  这孩子不会说话
Shure: This kid can't talk properly.
Shure:  领导都把话递到这了
Shure: The leader already hinted at it.
Shure:  哈哈哈哎呦我的
Shure: Hahaha, oh my.
Shure:  妈呀这是为什么
Shure: Why is this happening?
Shure:  你们导师好啊
Shure: You guys have good advisors.
Jake: 导师确实
Jake: The advisor is indeed...
陌生人：只有只有好的导师才会招最强的人
Stranger: Only good advisors recruit the best people.
陌生人：你知道吗
Stranger: You know?
陌生人：一般好的都一抢而空
Stranger: Generally, the best ones are quickly taken.
陌生人：只有能力强才能抢到这种名额
Stranger: Only those with great abilities can get such slots.
Shure:  别找补了
Shure: Stop making excuses.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Shure:  明年科员都不一定是了
Shure: Next year, you might not even be a clerk.
Shure:  哈哈你快去山东进修两年吧
Shure: Haha, you should go to Shandong for further studies for two years.
Alice: 哈哈山东
Alice: Haha, Shandong.
Shure:  山东
Shure: Shandong.
陌生人：90分有点夸张
Stranger: Scoring 90 is a bit exaggerated.
Shure:  我一多一分我都不要
Shure: I don't even want one more point.
Shure:  他只要给我60就行
Shure: Just give me 60, that's enough.
Tasha: 为什么要考90分
Tasha: Why do you need to score 90?
Lucia: 他考了90分
Lucia: He scored 90.
Tasha: 他考了90分
Tasha: He scored 90?
Tasha: 我还以为啊
Tasha: I thought...
Shure:  我说我要60分就行
Shure: I said 60 would be enough for me.
Shure:  你多一分都是多给我的都没有用
Shure: Any extra points are just useless to me.
陌生人：你企战是60吗
Stranger: Is your target 60?
Shure:  啊
Shure: Yeah.
Lucia: 企战
Lucia: Target?
Shure:  企站是什么
Shure: What is "target"?
Jake: 企业战略我都记得啊
Jake: I remember the corporate strategy.
Shure:  不是应该不是60
Shure: No, it shouldn't be 60.
陌生人：我真的我跟你们说
Stranger: Seriously, let me tell you.
陌生人：我就是我考试非常想提前
Stranger: I really wanted to finish the exam early.
陌生人：要捐吗然后呢
Stranger: Did you donate? And then...
陌生人：考试这考试其实我实在真的不会
Stranger: Actually, I really didn't know the exam.
陌生人：然后我本来是有时间复习的
Stranger: And I actually had time to review.
陌生人：但那边时间繁花太好看了
Stranger: But the flowers over there were too beautiful.
陌生人： 我刚才在看繁华
Stranger: I was just watching the flowers.
Lucia: 所以那个真的没复习
Lucia: So you really didn't review.
Shure:  我带他看哈哈哈
Shure: I took him to see the flowers, haha.
陌生人：然后考试的时候我三三十多分钟交卷
Stranger: Then during the exam, I handed in the paper in about thirty minutes.
陌生人：因为我一堂课没跟你差不多
Stranger: Because I never attended a single class.
陌生人：因为我一堂课没有去过
Stranger: I never attended a single class.
陌生人：所以我不知道老师长什么样
Stranger: So I didn't know what the teacher looked like.
陌生人：其实那个监考
Stranger: Actually, the invigilator...
陌生人：老师就是我们的老师
Stranger: The teacher was our teacher.
陌生人：但是我不知道
Stranger: But I didn't know.
陌生人：我以为他只是个小小学生
Stranger: I thought he was just a little student.
陌生人：我就直接交了
Stranger: So I just handed it in.
Lucia: 小学生
Lucia: Little student?
陌生人：我就直接
Stranger: I just...
陌生人： 我就直接交了
Stranger: I just handed it in.
陌生人：叫了之后还是他跟我说的
Stranger: After handing it in, he told me...
Shure:  老师在这阴阳怪气的
Shure: The teacher was being sarcastic.
Shure:  我拿他卷跟你讲啊
Shure: Let me tell you about his paper.
Shure:  就这种这么早交卷的
Shure: He handed it in super early.
Shure:  一字不写的
Shure: Didn't write a single word.
Shure:  不是不是不是没写几个字的
Shure: No, no, not even a few words.
Shure:  这肯肯定过不了
Shure: There's no way he could pass.
Shure:  那肯必须挂他
Shure: He definitely had to fail.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Lucia: 那最后没挂呀
Lucia: But in the end, he didn't fail.
陌生人：主要说老师你太好了
Stranger: Mainly because the teacher was too nice.
陌生人：可能看我写的屁话太多了
Stranger: Maybe they thought I wrote too much nonsense.
Shure:  不不是
Shure: No, no.
Shure:  然后他他他说完这番话我就添两个字
Shure: Then after he said that, I added two more words.
Shure:  我就咔就笑了哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: I just burst out laughing, hahaha.
陌生人：然后又回来把这个把这个噩耗传给我
Stranger: Then he came back to deliver the bad news.
Shure:  对对
Shure: Exactly.
Shure:  我就想想赶紧告诉他这个好消息
Shure: I just wanted to tell him the good news quickly.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
陌生人：然后我整个寒假都没播好
Stranger: And then I had a terrible winter break.
Shure:  我们两个
Shure: The two of us...
Lucia: 我感觉我们俩太傻逼了
Lucia: I feel like we're such idiots.
Jake: 学了一寒假企战
Jake: Studied business warfare all winter.
陌生人：还是不会学
Stranger: Still didn't get it.
Jake: 就是
Jake: Exactly.
Lucia: 学不了一点的
Lucia: Didn't learn a single thing.
Jake: 哈哈哈单身可以
Jake: Hahaha, being single is fine.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Shure:  我还有一门课
Shure: I had another class.
Shure:  因为平时有一次测测验没去
Shure: Missed a quiz once.
Shure:  就是平时小测
Shure: Just a regular quiz.
Shure:  然后我因为那天那个实习有有事
Shure: Because I had something for my internship that day.
Shure:  然后我就问那老师
Shure: So I asked the teacher.
Shure:  我说平时分
Shure: I said, for the usual grades...
Shure:  咱那个没过
Shure: If I didn't pass...
Shure:  但是我总成绩过了能不能给我过
Shure: But my overall grade was passing, could I pass?
Shure:  他说可以的
Shure: He said yes.
Shure:  然后结果最后给我挂了
Shure: But in the end, he failed me.
Shure:  然后让我重新补了一遍
Shure: Made me retake the quiz.
Shure:  平时小册
Shure: Just a regular quiz.
Shure:  唉就特别的耻辱
Shure: It was so humiliating.
Shure:  你知道吗
Shure: You know?
陌生人：有两门吧
Stranger: There are two classes, right?
陌生人：我记得有
Stranger: I remember there are.
陌生人：有一门平时不错
Stranger: One class is usually good.
陌生人：有一门平时不行
Stranger: The other class is usually not.
Shure:  唉我不知道
Shure: Sigh, I don't know.
Shure:  反正他不是他自己亲口说的
Shure: Anyway, he didn't say it himself.
Shure:  然后最后搞这种
Shure: And then he ends up doing this.
Shure:  唉
Shure: Sigh.
Jake: 走吧还眼镜
Jake: Let's go, still need the glasses.
Shure:  好disconnect finish
Shure: Okay, disconnect, finish.
Shure:  完了我这又没有那个finish那个键
Shure: Oh no, I don't have the finish button again.
Alice: 我也是哦
Alice: Me neither.
Alice: 好了
Alice: Okay.